pourquoi contester un pv parce qu'on
juge que la verbalisation elle est
excessive elle est abusive elle est en
dehors du cadre légal parce que on peut
justifier les raisons pour lesquelles et
bien on a pris sa voiture pour aller
faire des courses pour aller voir un
parent une érable pour aller chercher
aussi un enfant dans le cas de la garde
d'enfants pour rebondir sur ce que le
demander un internaute il ya un instant
il n'y a pas de distance prévue par la
réglementation c'est à dire que on peut
aller faire ses courses à 30 40 km ce
n'est pas interdit ce n'est pas prévu
par la réglementation
alors lorsqu'on estime effectivement
qu'on est verbalisé de manière excessive
parce que l'agent verbalisateur
considère de manière totalement ubuesque
que vous n'avez pas acheté assez de
denrées alimentaires
parce qu'il estime que votre déplacement
n'est pas justifiée et que tout
simplement vous avez l'envié de faire
valoir vos droits devant un tribunal
et bien vous pouvez contester cette
amende forfaitaire qui vous est envoyé
par la poste quelques jours après la
verbalisation étant précisé donc ça
c'est très important que pendant cette
période de confinement les délais de
contestation ont été multipliées par
deux c'est à dire que au lieu de pouvoir
contester son père et dans un délai de
45 jours suivant l'envoi dans l'avis de
contravention
eh bien les personnes verbalisées
dispose d'un délai de 90 jours pour
contester ce procès verbal alors comment
le conteste et bien non le contest soit
par lettre recommandée je ne conseille
pas d'abord pour des questions
financières et puis ensuite parce qu'il
faut se déplacer aller à la poste pour
le faire je conseille de le faire par le
site de lanta qui est un site officiel
de l'administration qui permet de
contester en ligne so procès verbal en
et joignant une copie de son avis de
contravention on a d'une part
immédiatement un récépissé qui permet de
justifier qu'on a bien contesté son
attraction
et puis eh bien on va motiver la
contestation
pourquoi je considère que l'agent
verbalisateur s'est trompé tout
simplement parce que je gêne être une
attestation j'ai un témoignage de la
personne vulnérable
je suis allé visiter qui dit
qu'effectivement elle avait besoin de
mes services
j'ai bien acheter des denrées
alimentaires j'ai un ticket de caisse
etc etc
on ne conteste pas pour contester ou
pour s'amuser bien naturellement parce
qu'il faut quand même bien expliquer à
nos auditeurs que quand on conteste
c'est soit le classement de la faire
c'est à dire qu'on va annulé le pv mais
c'est aussi majoritairement comme cela
d'ailleurs une saisine du tribunal est
donc une audience et le tribunal peut
passer de 135 à 750 euros
le goût de la demande donc on quand on
conteste on a des bonnes raisons et des
bonnes justifications de le faire règle
est très simple le bv fait foi jusqu'à
preuve du contraire c'est le principe
en gros pour résumer ce qu'a dit l'agent
verbalisateur c'est vrai c'est presque
incontestable sauf que on peut néanmoins
le contester mais on a une preuve qui
est limité cette preuve contraire qui
est limité
c'est l'attestation c'est l'écrit alors
ça va être par exemple
effectivement le ticket de caisse j'ai
été verbalisé à 11 heures alors que j'ai
un ticket de caisse qui montre qu à
10h55
j'ai bien fait mes courses et que je
revenais mon domicile peu importe ce que
vous avez acheté j'ai envie de vous dire
puisque on vous demande pas ce que vous
avez acheté on vous demande de justifier
d'un déplacement mais j'ai tellement
envie d'aller plus loin
vous n'êtes pas obligé d'acheter tout
court si vous motivez votre déplacement
pour un achat de première nécessité et
que finalement vous ne l'achetez pas
n'est pas obligé d'acheter non plus car
vous pourrez contesté en disant que
j'avais l'intention d'acheter un produit
vous n'avez pas acheté pour x ou y
raison et donc vous allez pouvoir avec
des attestations et bien justifier de
votre déplacement de la même manière si
vous allez voir un proche parent qui est
malade c'est une période une personne
tient en cette période là un besoin
impérieux de votre présence pour les
courses ou pour des raisons médicales et
bien son attestation doit permettre le
classement de ces [ __ ] juste un chiffre
quand même effarant on est à plus de 900
me pv dressés à ce jour c'est quand même
extrêmement important on voit que pour
le coup les forces de l'ordre n'ont pas
perdu la main sur les verbalisations